Sponsor, sponsor!
Yes, ah ah, ah
Finally
Aimcontrollers.com, baby.
That's right.
They designed a controller. It's very premium.
Look at that, it matches my chair
Not only can you customize your own design and make it very sexy like this one, but it also feels very premium.
It's got all these kinds of textures on it. You know, it just feels good in your hands. What can I say?
What's cool about this, is that you guys are gonna be able... I'm giving you this opportunity, that's right,
To design the official (this is just a prototype) design of the PewDiePie controller
Which will be sold worldwide, baby! [hell yeah] So check out the link description for this webpage. It works better on computer.
Basically, it's very simple. You can just upload any picture..
See?!? Already this looks insanely good.
You can customize the grip texture color,
You can customize the paddles in the back,
Anything on this baby, you can customize,
So, I want you guys to be creative, (you) can be artistic,
You can make meme-worthy ones, (you) can even change the text on the back and (on) the front and write whatever.
I'll write my gamertag 'iloveass2', I'll pick the winner next week.
So, submit your designs and again.. Thanks aimcontrollers.com for sponsoring this video. Very nice product.
Check it out. Now without further ado, Let's jump into it.
(LWIAY Theme Song)
Alright, since reddit has changed now, I'm just gonna go from top to bottom from now on. "Instead of fighting an Indian"
"Why not become one? I am NOT Indian, by the way." Thank you for clarifying
"I am an Indian and this is on trending here. Don't worry pewds. We got you. Just title your next video as"
"Jai Hindi (hail India) and put the Indian flag in the thumbnail and click"
"bait the title as "I am half Indian""
"Watch it blow up." I feel like this is bait
to put me in trouble
But I also think it's a great clickbait, so it cancels out. Alright, we'll try this out
You better not be trolling me. I swear to God. In case you don't know the context, that's right, this channel is at war
We're at war everybody
Against the Indian. The Indian Channel T-Series is about to overtake this channel in just the span of a few months
Jai Hind
"-Humility is a virtue. I don't want to be the biggest channel. -That is why it must be you"
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of channels
More appropriate than me to be number one
And I'm pretty sure it's not me and I'm pretty sure it's not T-Series, ok? This guy said it was his last day
Sorry
McDonald's merch, that is awesome
(kills memes)
Upgrade
Absolute MADLAD
I finally made it into the LWIAY and made
PewDiePie smile, I will cherish this moment forever. That is not a smile
Ok, I didn't smile. Ok, so whatever
Whatever moment of happiness, you got just delete it. Ok, cuz it gave me nothing
Nothing. He said on LWIAY he would bring it back. Maybe he forgot. Let's remind him again. Oh, yeah. Next week!
Ok, we're doing the... We're doing the controller thing , alright. Let's do that first, then the week after we'll do the green screen
Okay, what is this?
This is not PewDiePie lore, okay
Out of all things that we put in the videos to create lore
This?
This is what you're focusing. Yeah. Okay. No, you got us they we have to I get the joke, but for real
Why does the mirror the video, it's obviously a call or help. Okay, I don't mirror the video for anything
It means nothing. Okay, stop reading into nothing, Jesus
The absolute madlad. "Gave myself a ticket so that they won't"
Okay, this is not worthy of absolute madlad.
Madlad, perhaps. Okay, I do this all the time. That's right
If you ever get a ticket, just save it and then put it on your car so you won't get another one
Although it doesn't work cuz they give you another one anyways. Ligma died of ninja. What's ni-
You know he's married, right
the Curious Case of Felix Kjellberg. Late 2017
early 2018
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
He's becoming part of the nine year old army himself
Once we have defeated all the Indians and I have transformed into a nine year old myself
I shall become more powerful than you can possibly imagine. This is how we count years on the Pewdiepie Channel. Ten years old
Nine years old plus one. Bonus year, bonus year. That's right. I am nine plus
Twenty one bonus years.  Damn, I'm really old, Jesus
Wait
Twenty... No, wait
19, 19 bonus... Math, how does it work? Nineteen? I said 19. I said 19. Shut up. The gang is all here
We are all taking a stance against the Indians on YouTube.
T-Series must be stopped. This is just some sort of joke
Okay, it's not just about me being the biggest subscribed channel. It's about doing what's right.
We have Mr.Beast on our side. We have
Well, apparently Jake Paul's on our side. Vladimir Putin
All right, fine. Kim Jong-Un... I didn't know he had a Twitter. Logan Paul is on our side. Wow, amazing. Thank you
What a strong army of nine-year-olds
Petition to change up votes and down votes into brofist and T-Series. Petition denied
Okay, but then Australians will have brofist as down vote.
With the wedding getting closer, let's remind- Stop reminding me of stuff.
I say a lot of things. Okay. Stop hopping
What I say now
Oh
It's this one. "Have to wear a full-body
Leotard on your wedding day or have the person you are marrying wear the full body-"
Please guys, please
No
All right, you can remind me all you want, the date hasn't happened yet
I never back out on my word. I'm a man of my word. I always do everything I say I will
Anyone... Any of y'all think Mr. Beast
should make a video of him making
Ten- A hundred thousand YouTube accounts to subscribe to Pewdiepie.
Pewdiepie's subreddit wants me to do this but what these nine year olds don't realize is I've been doing this all along. How do you think he became one?
Well, do a better job then, Jesus Christ. Mr. Beast, please
Amp up the pace, man. Come on. Oh, there it is. Someone already made it for me
Perfect
It looks awful, but I'll take it. I'll take it.
Scientists have developed the first telescoping contact lens
This lens is capable of zooming your vision three times
All we asked for was to exit YouTube while playing music
Oh
my god
It was me all along. Does anyone know what happened to this channel?
Like they're just deleting their videos now. But why, what is the reason.
There is an Indian conspiracy, I swear, it is
I don't like this
Who's voting for T-Series, what is this?
Actual footage of
pdp-10
challenging T-Series. Since T-Series is kind of like Indian vivo, it doesn't count. Yes, it does! Yeah
We need to stop before it's too late
People are talking about T-Series like it will take over and I say nay, Indians
Try again next time
Okay
That's it for this week's Lawa.  As always, thank you guys for posing all the memes. I very much appreciate it. It's always fun
I'm so proud that we have this community and I can't wait to see where you guys are gonna
Submit for the aim controller design. Should we do the highest voted one wins? I feel like that one just makes it I
Don't know. Yeah. Sure. Let's do that. Thanks for smashing like and subscribing. I'll see you guys tomorrow with another video